hey guys what's up you're watching DLM
model lifestyle and I'm Daniel Moritz
now in this video I'm gonna answer your
question how much do models make let's
get into this
hi if this is your first time on my
channel subscribe and hit the bell so
you won't miss the next video alright so
how much do models really make the truth
well I'm gonna cover all of that but
watch until the answer is you can get my
best tips on how to really make money in
modeling so the first important thing is
guys and girls get paid differently
girls get paid almost two times as much
those guys know yeah that is not fair
but that is how it is now on the rest of
the world people complain that you
should not be paid less based on your
sex right well in modeling guys are
still paid a lot less than girls but
that being said there are also a lot
more jobs for girls than there is for
guys now that's not normally a good
thing because there are also a lot more
girls so the competition for girls is a
lot bigger so how much can you really
get paid well the truth is you can get
paid anything from absolutely nothing
for free yes you're not guaranteed any
money in this industry but it can go up
to millions yes millions but only for
supermodels and they are less than one
point probably 0.1% I would say there is
also a huge difference between
international modeling and modeling in a
certain country international modeling
that's a lot different you work on
contracts you go to for two or three
months to a specific country if you work
really well you can extend it and you
can stay a little bit longer and so in
that specific country they pay you a
specific amount so that's different some
countries like China pay per hour right
in some countries pay for a half day and
today and it's all different okay I just
want to apologize for the noises in the
background because I cannot find a quiet
place here anyway so please bear with me
alright alright so let's just recap guys
and girls get paid differently you can
get paid anything from absolutely
nothing to millions and the third thing
is countries pay differently now I have
looked at some of the YouTube videos and
I am a little bit shocked by what some
of the models would say they would say
hey you can get paid anything from 1000
US to 10,000 per day well that's not
true that's only if you get a job and
jobs don't come easily if you don't have
a job you get paid absolutely nothing it
doesn't work like a normal job you don't
get paid per month you only get paid for
the jobs that you do now you get paid
for different kind of jobs
there's showrooms this photoshoot is TV
commercials it's fashion shows there's a
lot of different jobs now showrooms and
fashion shows and the vans Dave they are
the jobs that well they don't really pay
that well photo shoots pay a little bit
more but it depends on what kind of
photo shoot you do e-commerce doesn't
play that well and then you get better
photo shoot where you get paid more if
it is for campaigns or for stills print
and that kind of stuff and then TV
commercials man they pay the most
[Music]
another factor that comes into play is
models get fake differently because of
their rank and their experience so while
as I mean well when you start out
modeling you start out brand you don't
have a lot of good photos and you don't
have good experience but as the years
pass you portfolio looks at a lot better
to present to the clients and you have a
lot more experience so you get paid more
for the jobs now different agencies also
have different reputations and so they
also have different prices for example
Turkey Istanbul the agencies there have
different prices for their models so if
you go good agency you might get a
little bit more money if you go with
so-so agency you might get a little bit
less money but some agencies are also
very good but they just drop the prices
so that they can get more jobs so be
very careful when you choose agency now
the main question everybody has is how
much does the average the model make
well well to be honest the average model
is struggling to survive
so they get second and third jobs it's
not that easy to be a model right now it
used to be a lot easier even when I
started that it used to be less agencies
and less models so less competitions now
what happened is you have Booker's that
work with an agency for a few years and
then they leave and then they start
their own agency so the agencies just
get bigger and more so what happens is
they get more models and more models and
there's not enough jobs for everybody
that is the truth now some of you have
asked how much do I make don't know how
much money do you make us and is it
risky well for me on some contracts I
have made nothing that just happens test
risk that comes with Marlon but some of
my best contracts I've made up to 30,000
US dollars which is a lot of money right
but I did not make thirty thousand US
dollars when I started out as a model
that comes with experience and the more
you portfolio grows and as you grow you
get smarter with castings in the
countries that you go to in the
decisions that you make with your
modeling career and you also need a very
good mother agency so guys what I'm
trying to say here is there is no
guarantee in how much money you can make
in modeling it's very hard for different
kind of people and it really depends on
the way you carry yourself
remember what Gavin said but ultimately
it's about setting your son so can you
walk into your home and sell yourself
does the client want you to be the name
and face of that package whatever the
product may be so it's about the world
or it's about selling yourself and it's
about being professional but a lot of
people don't realize
that is it John and if you're a
secretary or doctor or lawyer
you shut up on time you make your
appointments your act in a professional
way and being a model it has the same
requirement so it's about the husband
book but it was a how you conduct
yourself because it's easy to say I'm a
male model but am i working a male model
that's where the difference is so yes
your look and your height and your size
but also how professional and that's
what can make you a successful model my
name is Mark reeling especially for
girls because there's a lot of work
there's a lot of travel you need to be
physically and mentally to be a
successful model you see it really
depends on how you carry yourself the
decisions that you make modeling can be
awesome you can go to these most amazing
places but it does come with a lot of
sacrifices and a lot of challenges I'll
make a video about the cost of modeling
just so you know how hard it can be and
I'll talk about some personal
experiences that I had in my life I know
some of these stuff is maybe not
something that you expect it but I'd
rather really speak the truth so that
you know how it really works now I told
you I will tell you the best ways to
make money if you watch to view it to
the end so here we go
the number one build your book up as
fast as you can if you cannot pay for
photoshoots go online to websites like
model mayhem and other websites and look
for photographers that are also new and
they are also looking to build their
portfolios up and then you start to talk
to them and say hey can we do a photo
shoot where you use my photos for your
book and I'll use your photos for my
book and then you build a portfolio up
it might not be that great at the
beginning but you'll have a lot more
pictures and the clients and see the
different kind of poses that you can do
and what you can really bring to them
and as time goes on all the jobs that
you do make sure you write those names
down yeah
those pictures and remember clients are
stingy photographers as well sometimes
they say hey I'll send you the pictures
but they don't I think I've only gotten
around 30% of all the photos that I did
in my whole modeling career so it's hard
to get the photos write down the name
and if the client or photographer don't
want to give you the pictures go and
look for it online when it is available
second get a very good mother agency
that believes in you and your talents
it's very very hard and there's been so
many of my friends I just had bad
agencies that don't believe in them and
they just don't get anywhere with their
modeling career so make sure you choose
the right agency if they don't really
care about you
don't stick around get another agency
that believes in you
sometimes the mistake models do is that
I try to go for all the big names big
agencies and then I go for them but
there are so many models and what ends
up happening is there are just another
number so they don't get the attention
that they need you need that attention
especially at the start of your modeling
career but there are also bigger
agencies that are really good and they
do really care so try to find an agency
that will really care about your
modeling career and about your own
future now my third tip is when you
start traveling you go to all the
international markets right it's a lot
of fun but then you start realizing in
which markets you work really well for
example you might go to let's say Paris
and you don't work that well but then
you go to Germany and you work a lot
more you go to China and it's like not
so good then you go to South Korea and
Wow something you start to work so you
start to realize which markets suit your
specific look
and then what you do is after a few
years you just go over those markets
where you work really well why well
because you start to build more clients
so when you go the first time you might
make only four thousand us next time you
go you might make seven then the third
time you go you might make twelve and
then it just increases because we need
to come back the clients and the studios
remember you and they're like hey
paulie's bad Jennifer is back hey we'd
like to work with her again and sell
your client base grossly daddy's how a
model really start to make money all
right my fourth tip is guaranteed
contracts now what is a guaranteed
contract now a guaranteed contract is
basically a contract that guarantees you
money it means an agency offers you a
contract where they say hey come over
here work of us for two or three months
and we guarantee you a specific amount
of money of let's say four thousand US
dollars eight thousand US dollars or
more it depends on the quality of model
that you are have put your book is and
how much experience you have
unfortunately guaranteed contracts are
only offered to really good models
that's been working for a few years but
as time goes on and you're good grows
and you grow you will get
now I also just want to add that you
don't need to go to a modeling school to
start modeling if an agency believes in
you they will help you to get where you
need to go because they are in charge of
organizing and helping your model career
grow so you don't need a model school
especially a model school that is not a
model agency there are also models
called acclaim that they can get you
jobs but it's a lie they just want you
to pay them then fall for it all right
now go check out the videos on my
youtube channel there's a playlist about
modeling that it'll really help you out
now if you really want to get a lot more
tips about castings how to make money
all these kind of stuff and also the
countries you can travel to there's a
lot of stuff that I talked about in my
model book I've added the link here in
the description down below so check it
out now if you're new on my channel and
you like the video subscribe and I'll
see you in the next video
[Music]
[Music]